Speaker 1: This weekend, there was another one of
these so-called Save America rallies in Florence,
South Carolina. Now I don't need
to explain to you the irony that
if the people who speak at these
Save America rallies were in power,
we would destroy America. And case in point, this
particular rally in Florence, South Carolina,
Donald Trump was speaking in theory in support
of 2022 candidates. Now, the funny thing is,
Trump can really only talk about himself. So there
was about an hour speech, shorter speech than
normal, actually only about 50 minutes, I think,
because it was cold out. And when it's cold out,
Donald Trump's speeches are much shorter.
He only allowed the two candidates to speak
for like 30 seconds each at the very end. And
so it was hard to tell that it was supposedly
a rally support supporting 20 22 candidates. But
it doesn't matter because it's all about Trump.
Trump was visibly swollen. His both eyes were
swollen, almost completely shut. I still don't
understand why that happens. It's a very strange
thing. But here is Donald Trump all but confirming
that he's running in 2024? Take a listen.
Speaker 4: Take back the Senate and we are going
to take back America. And in 2024, we are going to
take back that beautiful, beautiful White House.
Yeah, I wonder who will do
that? I wonder. I wonder.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So listen, clearly at this
point, Trump's plan is to run unless unless
he gets sick and is and can't run, you know,
I mean, it's going to be close to 80 years old
at the time. No, no one's health is guaranteed.
Statistically speaking, when you're almost 80,
your health is less guaranteed than when
you're almost 70 and almost 16. OK, I mean,
we're talking about math here, but it seems
pretty clear that he's going to run if he can.
And by pretending you're sort of not yet fully
announcing it, he wants to avoid having to file
financial disclosure reports. That's really the
only reason I can think of not to announce it yet.
Donald Trump, then, beyond parody, calls Joe Biden
physically and mentally challenged.
Speaker 4: Joe Biden failed to deter Rush's
outrageous invasion of Ukraine. You can take the
five worst presidents in American history and
put them together, and they would not have done
the damage Joe Biden has done in just 13 months.
We have a president representing our country
at the most important time in history who
is physically and mentally challenged.
Speaker 1: Now there are real. The guy in
the glass house should not be catapulting stones
at others. I think I don't know that we need to
say more about that. Donald Trump did address the
Russian invasion of Ukraine, but not as such. He
vaguely refers to conflict in Eastern Europe and
how lack of respect is a factor in what's going
on. He doesn't really criticize Putin directly
like he. He says Putin has been driven to put
it together, which is really strange language.
It feels as though Trump is kind of trying to
support Ukraine without really going after Putin.
Speaker 4: And for all the talk about violent
conflict in Eastern Europe, and it's a terrible
thing and we're going to help and we're going
to do whatever we can because nobody can look at
the bloodshed much longer. What's happening? It's
a lack of respect for a lot of people, a lot of
things, but it's just a total lack of respect. And
it happens to be a man that is just driven. He's
driven to put it together, and you look at it and
it's just so ridiculous and so senseless. And so,
Speaker 1: so yeah, I mean, when you hear that,
it's like, I think he's against the Russian
invasion of Ukraine. But he says the issue
is respect and Putin's driven to put it together.
Like, why can't he just straightforwardly condemn
the actions of Putin and Putin himself? Why is
that so difficult then? And this is where it
really gets to be beyond parody? Trump takes
credit for giving military aid to Ukraine.
Ignoring that he was impeached because he withheld
the aid, trying to get Zelensky to give him dirt
on Biden and announce an investigation into Biden.
Now he wants credit for having given the military
aid that he was shamed into giving to Ukraine.
Speaker 4: Remember that with Ukraine,
I sent the javelins that you see are so effective
against the tanks. Biden didn't, and in fact,
he ended our last order. Probably it'll get there
because everyone realized it was the right thing
to do. And Obama remember Obama, Biden? They
sent. I it's I sent Javelins and they said, well,
you know what, the Japanese are the anti-tank.
Speaker 1: Yeah, the Java Islands. Listen,
Trump tried not to send the aid to Zelensky
so that Zelensky would announce that he was
investigating Joe Biden, and then he was shamed
into sending the aid because Colonel Vindman,
Lieutenant Colonel Vindman, outed all of it.
Trump was shamed into sending the aid. Now he
wants credit for it then, and this is bizarre.
Trump calls on his supporters to lay down
their lives to fight critical race theory. What
who would do that and why would you need to?
Who critical race theorists are going to
kill people who don't like critical rigging?
Speaker 4: What anything? Getting critical race
theory out of our schools is not just a matter of
values. It's also a matter of national survival.
We have no choice. The fate of any nation
ultimately depends upon the willingness of its
citizens to lay down, and they must do this lay
down their very lives to defend their country.
If we allow the Marxists and communists and
socialists to teach our children to hate America,
there will be no one left to defend our flag or to
protect our great country or its freedom.
Speaker 1: This is a prototypical fascist
propaganda, reactionary, fascist propaganda.
Imagine even believing you might even have
the opportunity to die for, or, I guess, fighting
against critical race theory. It's and this is one
of these examples of critical theory. I am not
a critical theorist. I'm not a post-modernist,
et cetera. But much like Gen. Mark Milley said,
it's not about wanting to be for or against
these things necessarily. It's about studying
them and understanding them. Imagine if I said
I'm willing to die against the teaching of
existentialism, you would say, David, that's
extraordinarily stupid. It's not very different
with what they're talking about with critical
race theory. They don't know what it is. They know
they're against it, but they are weaponizing it.
And you end up. The logical conclusion is Trump
saying you might have to die against critical race
theory. Then remember, Republicans want to reduce
the power of the president. But here's Trump
saying we should add a new presidential power.
Speaker 4: We will pass critical reforms,
making every executive branch employee firable
firable by the president of the United States.
The deep state must and will be brought to heel.
Speaker 1: It's so Trump openly promoting the deep
state conspiracy theory. But remember,
they claim to be for small government
against the president having too much power.
But he is saying No, no, no, no, no. Let's give
the president more power to have any federal
employee be firable directly by the president.
Trump then seemingly confused about beautiful
blood. I don't even know what this means and
Speaker 4: pure, unflinching carriages
coursing through our veins. A beautiful,
beautiful blood red, white and blue.
Speaker 1: We will beautiful red, white and blue
blood. Folks, it is a beautiful thing. So Trump's
rally in South Carolina highlighted a few things.
No one even rallies meant to be for other
people really are about Trump. The rally was
supposedly for some candidates. They barely
spoke until the very end 30 seconds, and all
they basically had to do was say how great Trump
was. It's all about Trump number two. He clearly
is running in 2024 unless something changes with
regard to his health or maybe his ability to win
the nomination if he got wind, that he definitely
has no shot. Maybe he wouldn't run. And number
three, he's repeating the same unoriginal stuff at
this point, and a big part of his appeal in 2016
was he was saying new things. They were
unexpected. They were wild. They were wacky.
They no longer are that anymore. But there
are still quite literally tens of millions of
people who seem OK voting for the same failed
talking points, which, if Trump were to win,
would lead to global humiliation even greater
than when Trump won last time. But also absolutely
sorry hit my mike there. Absolutely
nothing getting done for another four years